[Musik]
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
guten abend an einem gefühlten montag
der doch ein dienstag ins christian otto
heute mit dem blick auf die fußballer
zusammen und so hat deutschland gegen
england mega guten abend und hier sind
unsere themen des tages
der kanzler und die sorgen der
verbündeten angesichts der russischen
bedrohung sagt scholz den baltischen
staaten mehr deutsche soldaten zu
wem nützt der tank rabatt den
verbrauchern oder er den
mineralölkonzernen die forderung zu hohe
gewinne abzuschöpfen wird lauter
das zugunglück und die frage nach der
ursache die staatsanwaltschaft ermittelt
jetzt gegen drei mitarbeiter der banken
zu langsam zu spät zu zögerlich lautet
die kritik wenn es um deutsche
waffenlieferungen und die ukraine
politik geht diese kritik schlug olaf
scholz nicht nur hier bei uns entgegen
auch litauen lettland und estland ging
alles zu langsam
heute traf der bundeskanzler in litauen
die staats- und regierungschefs aller
drei baltischen länder sie fühlen sich
an der nato ost lanke besonders von
russland bedroht und fordern mehr
unterstützung
aktuell ist die bundeswehr mit etwa 1000
soldatinnen und soldaten vor ort und es
sollen mehr werden kündigte scholz heute
an natalie steger berichtet
strategisch sensibel für die nato liter
und hat gleich zwei schwierigen nachbarn
an seinen grenzen belarus auf der einen
russland auf der anderen seite trotzdem
fühlt sich der grenzschützer sicher sagt
er denn hinter ihm stehe jemand der im
ernstfall hilft er meinte der
bundeskanzler in der litauischen
hauptstadt mehr als 100 tage hat er
gebraucht seit kriegsbeginn wie es eher
in einen start an der nato ostflanke
wir werden im falle eines angriffs jeden
zentimeter des nato territoriums
verteidigen außerdem gespräche mit den
baltischen regierungschefs zur ukraine
alle drei hatten die zögerliche haltung
deutschlands in sachen lieferungen von
kampfpanzern wochen lang kritisiert
jetzt will man nach vorne blicken ich
freue mich sehr von ihrer entscheidung
zu hören luftabwehrsysteme an die
ukraine zu liefern die schnelle
lieferung hat eine schlüsselbedeutung um
den aggressor abzuwehren russland will
für den krieg nicht gewinnen formuliert
es erneut der kanzler russland müsse
verlieren die balken
es gibt keinen dialog oder kooperation
geben keine peas mit oder zugeständnisse
gegenüber eine stadt mit
imperialistischen ambitionen
besuch bei den nato truppen in litauen
unter deutscher führung scholz will weg
vom image des zauberers das deutsche
engagement soll verstärkt werden in
richtung einer robusten kampf private
gehe
für olaf scholz wehrte sich dieser
besuch gelohnt haben denn er bekam hier
unerwartete rückendeckung ausgerechnet
von den staaten die bisher immer am
lautesten eine größere unterstützung
auch mit schweren waffen für die ukraine
gefordert haben dass er das lob bekommen
hat alle drei baltischen staaten für den
bisherigen einsatz deutschlands dürfte
auch daran liegen dass er hier
versprochen hat die unterstützung
deutschlands und die führung
deutschlands bei den nato einsatzkräften
in litauen zu erhöhen er geht also hier
persönlich mit einer guten bilanz nach
hause
der ukrainische präsident lenski
schließt eine waffenruhe mit russland
derzeit aus man habe schon zu viele
menschen verloren um territorien
abzutreten sagte er jetzt gehe es darum
alle verlorenen gebiete zurückzuerobern
besonders umkämpft ist weiter die gegend
um die industriestaaten wie rodong jetzt
dort ändere sich die situation von
stunde zu stunde erklärte der
bürgermeister bilder aus dem
benachbarten lässig anzeigen die
zerstörung durch anhaltenden
artilleriebeschuss sollte die ukraine
beide städte verlieren wäre die region
luhansk vollständig in russischer hand
wir gehen jetzt in den süden der ukraine
an die schwarzmeerküste nach odessa die
hafenstadt ist weltberühmt für opern aus
die philharmonie und eine architektur
aus der zeit von katharina der großen
kulturstaatsministerin roth war dort
jetzt zu gast um ein zeichen zu setzen
und um unterstützung zu signalisieren
unterstützung zum erhalt der stark
bedrohten kulturellen identität johannes
hano
es war ein besuch auf einladung ihres
ukrainischen amtskollegen alexander
jacob ukraine ein wichtiger besuch in
schweren zeiten rundgang zwischen
sandsäcken durch die altstadt von odessa
schwer bewacht und immer die gefahr von
raketenangriffen was er sich von dem
besuch claudia roth erwartet fragen wir
den minister sie meinen leben
kampfflugzeugen
ich denke die tatsache dass ihre
ministerin nach odessa gekommen ist ist
eine wichtige symbolische geste dass
europa den schutz des ukrainischen
kulturerbes ernst nimmt
die kulturstaatsministerin lässt sich
zeigen was bei dem russischen angriff
der hier jederzeit erwartet wird
verloren gehen würde besuch in der
weltberühmten oper von odessa und in der
staatsbibliothek aus angst vor
russischen angriffen hat die mehr als
fünf millionen bücher in sicherheit
gebracht und versteckt und schließlich
die philharmonie man werde die ukraine
dabei unterstützt nur des altstadt und
ihre einzigartigen kulturstätten schnell
zum weltkulturerbe ernennen zu lassen um
die stadt sofa russischer zerstörung zu
bewahren denn russland verfolge mit
seinen angriffen auf kulturstätten in
der ganzen ukraine einen perfiden plan
ist ein systematischer versuch aus zu
löschen was kultur in diesem land
ausmacht und die ukraine und ukrainerin
sagen ja zu recht ist es unsere kultur
und die soll zerstört werden am ende
ihres kurzbesuch arm in arm mit roman
schwarzmann blumen für die 25.000
ermordeten juden von odessa spaß man hat
als kind das massaker überlebt und er
sagt dass wladimir putin mit seiner
strategie der auslöschung der
ukrainische nation nicht anders handeln
würde als adolf hitler
kulturstaatsministerin claudia roth ist
gesprächsgast im zdf spezial zum ukraine
krieg direkt nach uns trotz sprit
steuersenkung steigen die benzin und
dieselpreise seit tagen wieder an riesen
frust bei vielen autofahrern und
aufkommen der ärger in der berliner
ampel weil spd und grüne nämlich eine
zusätzliche steuer auf sogenannte über
gewinne ins spiel bringen die auch die
gut verdienende mineralölbranche
betreffe nicht zu machen mit der fdp die
heute vor populismus warnt alexandra
vacano
diese für 195 super e10 für 192 und 198
für super die preise heute mittag an
einer freien tankstelle in düsseldorf
210 oder so etwas wo sind denn die 35
cent
java ist wie es ist wenn die 30 cent
rabatt haben sich dann nicht so richtig
ausgezahlt gemacht am ersten juni gingen
die preise noch nach unten e5 und e10 um
27 cent diesel im durchschnitt um 11
dann aber wieder preisanstieg um circa
fünf bis sechs cent da kommt deutlich zu
wenig bei den verbrauchern an
kritisierte adac auch mit dem
zunehmenden abverkauf der restbestände
mit dem alten steuersatz müssten die
spritpreise fallen es wäre sinnvoll
gewesen dass man diesen tank rabatt wenn
er schon eingeführt wird auch
tatsächlich dazu verpflichtet die
konzerne dazu verpflichtet dass sie
diesen auch uneingeschränkt weiter geben
aber wir wissen einfach aus dem
mineralölmarkt das dem arischen
erfahrungsgemäß immer nach oben gehen
das kartellamt solle doch bitte genauer
hinschauen so die politik doch die
behörde kann nur zuschauen die konzerne
sind in der preissetzung frei es gibt
keine gesetzliche verpflichtung die
absenkung der steuern an die
verbraucherinnen und verbraucher
weiterzugeben was wir tun können ist das
was wir im moment machen eben maximale
transparenz bei der preisgestaltung
herstellt was also tun aus der spd die
idee krisen und kriegsgewinnler stärker
zu besteuern die grünen sinnieren über
einen stopp des tank rabatt aus der fdp
heißt es dazu heute nein es ist eben
eine welt
marktentwicklung und angesichts einer
welt marktentwicklung jetzt noch mit
einer zusätzlichen steuer nur in
deutschland zu reagieren kann am ende
dazu führen dass die preise an der
zapfsäule noch weiter steigen neuer
zwist für die ampel und spritpreise bei
denen erst mal keine entspannung in
sicht ist
zum zugunglück bei garmisch
partenkirchen da ermittelt jetzt die
staatsanwaltschaft münchen 2 gegen drei
mitarbeiter der bahn mit dem verdacht
auf fahrlässige tötung
der regionalzug war am freitag entgleist
mehrere waggons waren die böschung
heruntergestürzt fünf menschen starben
mehr als 40 wurden verletzt
und wir gehen zu alexander pohl erst an
der unglücksstelle alexander die
staatsanwaltschaft ermittelt jetzt also
gegen drei bahnmitarbeiter was heißt das
denn
das bedeutet das einen anfangsverdacht
gegen diese drei bahnmitarbeiter gibt
ein anfangsverdacht das ist eine sehr
niedrige stufe des verdacht also noch
viel weniger und die staatsanwaltschaft
dürfte gar nicht ermitteln
die polizei hat uns jetzt gesagt es geht
in solchen fällen dann immer um die
person die in unmittelbarem zusammenhang
stehen mit dem unglück das könnte also
der lokführer sein das könnte der
fahrdienstleiter sein es könnte auch der
strecken verantwortliche seien hier für
den abschnitt auf dem das unglück
passiert ist all das will die
staatsanwaltschaft heute leider noch
nicht bestätigen sie sagt daraus geht
die unschuldsvermutung das heißt klar
gegen die drei gegen die jetzt ermittelt
wird das bedeutet eben nicht dass die
sich automatisch schuldig gemacht haben
ermittelt wird jetzt auch er mit blick
auf den technischen defekt an den
gleisen oder dem gleisbett aber hier
muss man auch ganz klar sagen bis die
ermittlungen abgeschlossen sind das hat
man uns heute gesagt da können noch
monate vergehen also noch eine ganz
schön lange zeit dankeschön alexander
pohl für die aktuellen informationen
außenministerin berbalk hat in pakistan
ihre mehrtägige auslandsreise
abgebrochen weil sie sich offenbar mit
dem corona virus infiziert hat ein
schnelltest war positiv sie wird morgen
nach deutschland zurückkehren
ursprünglich wollte sie nach
griechenland weiter reisen und dann
gespräche in der türkei führen
extremismus in deutschland ist ein
problem das immer größer wird und dabei
ist es mit den einordnungen in links und
rechts nicht getan der neue
verfassungsschutzbericht zeigt nämlich
dass extremismus in immer mehr
schattierungen auftaucht die größte
gefahr wird allerdings im
rechtsextremismus gesehen er bedroht
laut innenministerin feser die
demokratie in deutschland
nicole diekmann berichtet ein
frühwarnsystem nannte
bundesinnenministerium feser den
verfassungsschutzbericht den sie heute
zum ersten mal vorstellte so warnen gilt
es vor einer ganzen menge so die
botschaft des
verfassungsschutzpräsidenten
das bwv war in seiner geschichte selten
in einer solchen umfassenden intensität
gefordert gegenwärtig die zahl der
rechtsextremisten wuchs auf 33.900
personen mehr als ein drittel gilt als
gewaltbereit auch die zahl der
linksextremisten stieg auf 34.700 hier
geht jeder vierte als gewaltbereit
lediglich die zahl der islamisten sank
leicht auf
28.200 90 nach wie vor sei die größte
gefahr der rechtsextremismus wir müssen
gerade jetzt angesichts der bedrohung
des friedens in europa durch putins
furchtbaren angriffskrieg gegen die
ukraine den inneren frieden in unserem
land stärken
denn wir wissen rechtsextremisten
missbrauchen jede krise für ihren
versuch menschen gegeneinander
auszuspielen und die gesellschaft zu
destabilisieren erstmals behandelt der
verfassungsschutzbericht die sogenannte
querdenker szene und nennt das phänomen
verfassungsschutz relevante die
legitimierung des staates dazu gehören
gezielte versuche der einschüchterung
etwa durch aufmärsche vor privathäusern
von politikern
zunehmend sorge bereitet den behörden
das thema cyber spionage und angriffe
wir gehen aktuell von einem erhöhten
risiko von cyber sabotage gegen
kritische infrastrukturen in deutschland
aus die afg steht noch nicht als
gesamtpartei im verfassungsschutzbericht
doch inzwischen gilt sie als
rechtsextremer beobachtungs fall dem gab
das verwaltungsgericht köln im märz
recht die partei hat nun berufung
eingelegt
auch das hat boris johnson erst einmal
ausgestanden
grossbritanniens premier überstand das
misstrauensvotum seiner eigenen
konservativen partei gestern abend
sprachen ihm 211 abgeordnete das
vertrauen aus 148 stimmten gegen ihn ein
knappes ergebnis dass johnson nach
ansicht vieler er schwächt der britische
premier steht wegen mehrerer partys in
seinem amtssitz während des corona lockt
downs unter druck und hat im land massiv
an zustimmung eingebüßt
am zweiten tag seiner nahost-reise hat
vizekanzler habe das westjordanland
besucht forderte aufklärung im fall der
journalist in china boakye die während
eines israelischen militäreinsatzes
getötet worden war der palästinensische
ministerpräsident starke verlangte
internationalen schutz für die
palästinenser und dankte deutschland für
die finanzielle hilfe zuvor hatte habeck
in der holocaust gedenkstätte yad vashem
der von den nazis ermordeten juden
gedacht
seit jahren wird es diskutiert aber doch
immer wieder verläuft es im sande ein
staatliches label für fleischprodukte
das auf einen blick klar macht wie das
tier gehalten wurde jetzt nimmt
landwirtschaftsminister erste mir einen
neuen anlauf und hat eckpunkte für ein
verpflichtendes logo vorgestellt bislang
ist vor allem dieses label in
supermarktregalen zu finden es gibt
unterschiedliche haltungsformen von
stufe 1 einfaches stallhaltung bis stufe
vier premium das neue staatliche logo
soll erst einmal nur für schweinefleisch
gelten mehr dazu erfahren wir jetzt von
molln
jedes schwein soll genug platz und
bewegung haben im stall von landwirt jan
hinrichs aus dem landkreis celle ein
staatliches tierhaltung kennzeichen hat
er längst für überfällig denn stelle
auszubauen für zufriedene schweine das
ist teuer landwirte bräuchten mehr
planungssicherheit
wir landwirte warten schon lange auf die
klaren regeln der politik die klaren
vorgaben dass wir endlich transparent
bis zum verbraucher durch dekorieren
dürfen wir möchten gerne investieren
können wir wissen um gleiche richtung
mehrere seiner vorgänger waren an einem
verbindlichen tierwohl label gescheitert
agrarminister cem özdemir stellt nun
seine pläne für eine verpflichtende
haltungs kennzeichnung für fleischwaren
vor wieland wird er am schließlich ein
recht darauf dass ihre leistungen zum
tierschutz anerkannt und gesehen werden
zugleich schafft die haltungs
kennzeichnung mehr transparenz für die
bevölkerung die verbraucherinnen die
verbraucher fordern diese transparenz
ein eingeführt werden sollen fünf
haltungs stufen steil die haltung
entspricht der gesetzlichen
mindestanforderung
schlossplatz mindestens 20 prozent mehr
fläche frischluft stahl mindestens eine
seite des stolzes offen auslauf freiland
ganztägiger auslauf mit mehr platz und
bio als extra kategorie
es ist ein staatliches label aber es
muss auch unterstützt werden mit einer
vor ort kontrolle denn die verbraucher
müssen sicher sein dass es den tieren
auch tatsächlich im stall besser
gegangen ist als an tieren wenn sie
höhere preise bezahlen die verbindliche
staatliche kennzeichnung soll im
kommenden jahr starten
verschiedene handys verschiedene
ladestecker damit ist ab mitte 2004 und
20 schluss darauf haben sich die eu
staaten und das eu parlament geeinigt
statt kabelsalat gibt es dann nur noch
eine einheitliche ladebuchse vom typ uh
sbc das gilt für neue smartphones und
auch etwa für tablets kameras und
kopfhörer so könnten knapp 1000 tonnen
elektroschrott eingespart werden
jährlich geschätzt 11.000 tonnen fallen
derzeit an durch und sorgte und nicht
benutzte ladegeräte
wir sind beim sport wir sind bei kristin
und bei der fußballnation sleek und da
steht ein fußball- klassikern das kann
man wohl sagen wenn deutschland gegen
england absolut um das ganze gibt es
nachher live im zdf beide unter zugzwang
beide bisher ohne sieg deutschland
immerhin schon mit einem punktgewinn
gegen italien die gäste aus england
kommen dagegen mit der niederlage gegen
ungarn nach münchen aber auch mit besten
erinnerungen
der klassiker tat damals england gut
sieg im achtelfinale der euro nun kommt
die nations league gerade recht
wir müssen konsequent sein gegen große
mannschaften gewinn eben gegen sie gut
zu spielen im zweiten spiel nations
league will der em-zweite nach der
niederlage gegen ungarn eine
wiedergutmachung ausgerechnet auswärts
in münchen mit der übernahme durch hansi
flick kann man schon die veränderungen
sehen die veränderungen im stil
natürlich gibt es an starken kern von
bayern münchen aber es ist gut die art
und weise wie sie das gegen pressing und
die pressing strategie umsetzen
die wertvollste mannschaft der welt
england gegen deutschland es geht um
prestige punkte und tore die vor einem
jahr england so gut getan habe
das will natürlich auch das deutsche
team katrin müller-hohenstein ihn in
münchen der bundestrainer war am samstag
nicht zufrieden was können wir nachher
erwarten also hansi flick hat ja bereits
angekündigt den einen oder anderen
wechsel vornehmen wird das betrifft am
ehesten die offensive
außenbahn er sagt aber auch erfreut sich
auf einen gegner auf augenhöhe fordert
mehr tempo mehr den von seinen spielern
als noch im spiel gegen italien wir
freuen uns dass bislang alles ruhig
geblieben ist auch bei den englischen
fans bei den berüchtigten englischen
fans in der stadt auch hier rund ums
stadion bislang alles ruhig alles
paletti und so melden uns dann ab 20 uhr
25 vom klassiker deutschland gegen
england live aus einem ausverkauften
stadion in münchen wunderbare kathrin
bis nach
neue altersregelung im eiskunstlaufen
das mindestalter für die teilnahme auf
großer internationaler bühne wurde auf
17 jahre angehoben schrittweise bis
olympia 2000 26
das umdenken wurde vehement nach dem
skandal um die damals 15 jährige russin
camilla belle war in peking gefordert
als sie nach tagelangen dopingvorwürfen
den erfolgsdruck in der kür nicht mehr
standhalten konnte ja das waren dann als
schöner bilder dann vielen dank
christian wir haben noch das für sie der
deutsche wetterdienst warnt aktuell vor
schweren gewittern in teilen baden
württembergs und bayerns mehr zum wetter
gleich von präsident ali in der fußball
hat seine pause gegen 21.30 meldet sich
christian sievers mit dem heute-journal
und wir sehen uns morgen wieder um 19
uhr schönen dunk und noch einen schönen
abend für sie
[Musik]
schokolade und herzlich willkommen zum
wetter neuer regen zieht auf und das aus
westlichen richtungen wird es im
tagesverlauf allmählich die mitte
erreichen und einzelne schauer und
gewitter können dann auch kräftiger
ausfallen
in der nacht gibt es letzte schauer zum
beispiel ganz im norden im westen und
auch an den alpen dazwischen lockert es
auf und durchaus nebel ist dann auch
dabei mit tiefsten temperaturen von
sieben grad in der norddeutschen
tiefebene oder am alpenrand 13 grad mild
bleibt es ganz im westen deutschlands am
vormittag morgen wolken verdichtung von
westen her und dann setzte etwas regen
ein allmählich stärker werden sonst im
osten bleibt es sonnig und trocken zum
nachmittag dehnt sich der regen weiter
in die mitte aus der ring kann durchaus
kräftiger ausfallen und dazu gibt es
dann gewitter dazu auch stürmische böen
kleinen könige hagel können bei
gewittern auch dabei sein im osten ist
es größtenteils weiterhin trocken
temperaturen dort bis 26 grad und 17
grad ganz im westen deutschlands am
donnerstag sehr durchwachsenes wetter
mit weiteren schauern bis 21 grad ab
freitag wärmer und 28 grad am samstag
ein schöner abend